um we want you to understand what what
we mean by internal aspects
internal aspects are what i do with his
energy
not necessarily what i do with my energy
although his energy
does become my energy
and not what i do externally nor
do i mean anything
hard to rationalize or hard to
understand
so i don't mean anything or anything
mystical
in the negative or pejorative sense of
the word
not in its accurate understanding
and i don't mean anything that's
antithetical to reason
although understanding it does not
necessarily mean you can do it
okay so i want to draw some
distinctions between some common
mistakes
that people and you might have regarding
what
are the internal aspects of the art okay
so a common one is
that my biomechanical efficiency
is understood as the internal aspects
because there's a there's an underlying
i don't understand what internal aspects
mean
but they sound good and i should have
them
and they should make me better off
having them to not having them
and so if i could do something or i feel
powerful or where i appear powerful
that must be the internal aspects
no it's just external biomechanical
efficiency
and that is a part of your martial art
okay so
an example of this is um
because i'm a bipedal machine with
this kind of chain link axis running
part way down my body
the way my structure is set up
where i will feel a lesser percentage of
my
force output potential being utilized
the larger muscle groups i use the more
of the rear posterior chain i use and
therefore
the closer that i am to the front center
line of my body
the more access i have to the rear
posterior chain
those larger muscle groups the smaller
percentage i'm using
of my force potential you will be
mechanically more efficient
than if you didn't do that but that is
not internal
the internal aspects of which we're
speaking up where i use his energy
so an example of this is um
if i if i don't let me pick my hand up
don't want to do that
so if i try to pick my hand up let's say
i'll put my elbow
further away from my body and i try to
pick my hand
up what happens is that my bicep gets
isolated
and this movement becomes dependent on
the strength of my bicep
but if i move my elbow closer to my
spine and in the center of my spine
and this move becomes very easy you see
see how i did that so we're going to
step out elbow is on the side here's my
spine line elbows on the side so on the
on the young shoulder line and my elbows
away from my body and you'll try to pick
that up
then move the elbow to at least the yin
line
if not to the transitional line and move
your elbow close your body
and then pick up the arm and you'll see
uh i
am using less of my force output
potential
okay so this is just an external
biomechanical efficiency it is not the
internal aspect so
let's try that okay the next thing you
can do
externally is you can play with the
geometry of your two
external frames so in that last one i'm
just engaging more of the rear cluster
your chain
but you can couple that or not couple it
with
just a kind of uh i have a better
mechanical geometry than he does
so for example um the
distal end of the lever is
is easier for me to move than when i'm
when i'm over here by this elbow
that's why you use levers to move
objects okay so
that's kind of what happened when i
brought myself closer and maybe you made
the mistake of lifting
by doing going that way but if you stay
on this line where his
lever is the longest it gets even easier
so
really really try i'm just going to lift
that up
that part up well it's even easier
okay so try it now as i increase my
biomechanical efficiency
i can also decrease his by my
biomechanical
efficiency as we go along so in the last
example i was just using it as it was
but
i can combine that with a continuing
decreasing so rather than just lift this
here
what i'm going to do is employ multiple
levers that keep getting that to
weaken okay so instead of lifting just
here
against his energy i now start to go
around his energy
by just applying another lever at the
elbow and another other level lever at
the wrist
okay and i'm just here and it's just too
it's just too easy you can't hold it
down hold it down
cannot hold it okay try it
so right now i've done nothing to his
energy
other than overpower it so this this is
not the internal aspect
but a lot of people go wow i feel so
powerful
this must be the thing i don't
understand
and so they try to make that call cue or
that ikey
it's not just biomechanical efficiency
it's something every athlete does okay
another thing that every athlete does is
they don't waste
any energy so one of the biggest signs
between a world-class athlete
and a newbie is how much tension
what would be mechanical retardation
they have
in their movement so you watch a
world-class
quality athlete and their movement looks
effortless
why because they're not flexing anything
more than has to be flexed and
definitely they're not flexing anything
that has nothing to do with the movement
but a beginner always retards their
movement by
over flexion or inappropriate flexion
so um all this was
was levers and but you'll see a beginner
will still do it quite
tense and what i'm going to do
is the same thing without any
unnecessary movement
very good grip it's very easy
and that actually plays such a large
role
even in aikido that you can get away
with that first one that you couldn't
get away with
just same thing put keep your weight
down on it
and my flex i feel very efficient but
i'm way out here
and just lift your hand or
he's pushing down and you're going to
want to try bring your elbows in
come up and you see that's all that
other stuff
rear posterior chain leverage
and a sounder geometry but again he's
pushing down on it
and just the relaxation and you can get
it up without any of that other stuff
okay
so now you're going back to this drill
and just let's let's have you first try
it close
so you're going to do the relaxation no
flexion
in the other sound biomechanical
geometry and as you're comfortable
you just get out from being outdoor
okay let's try okay so uh one of one of
the reasons why the new athlete
has unnecessary tension is they have
anxiety they
have anxiety due to the lack of
familiarity
okay so um you might have anxiety as you
try to do all your iq
because someone's grabbing you but you
will get the same
anxious induced flexion when you make
a combatant out of them someone that
you trying to overcome so if i'm here
and i i'm not like well he was not
letting me lift my hand
i've already started you don't realize
it but you already started flexing
okay so
one of the things you can do is imagine
something different
so i'm not going to let my mind go into
this uh threat foe overcome
context i just i'm changing my mind like
there's something up there that i
that i want okay now a lot of people
think that because i'm using my
imagination that this
is then internal this is not the
internal aspects
i'm just using my imagination okay
so this uh the same one is here
so when he's when he's pushing down if
you try to overcome him you'll flex
things that will stop your movement
right so
instead just uh imagine your hands are
floating
up and we can do this one
where he's on and you can use your your
symmetrical hand
like i want to touch my nose there's a
fly on my nose
and with my two hands i just am moving
uh my hands towards my nose to touch
that flap
i'm not trying to get him off my arm
okay
and again what this imagination does
is it helps the new person not enter
into that
threat faux overcome model which will
almost always induce
unnecessary flexion once you know what
relaxed motion feels like you don't need
your imagination
you can think whatever you want and get
it to go you can even think full
threat overcome and you will still move
correct okay
okay so at this point i have done
nothing external this is all external
stuff
even though i use my imagination i use
my imagination with an external aim
it's not that these things are not a
part of aikido
it's that they're not the whole of
aikido that is what is key what part are
they not the whole of the
internal aspects okay so um
you can get uh very high
in your skill level or in your force
output potential
by doing these things of course because
you're biomechanically sound
all right so if we take tenshi nugget
and it's the same thing
i'm going to have more biomechanical
soundness the more that i'm engaging
that rear posterior chain
so the closer my elbows are to me and to
the center line to my spine
the more mechanically efficient i am the
less tension i have in my arms
the more uh i'm going to be mechanically
sound so
i'm going to do tenshi nagas the same
thing
arms are very loose and he will feel a
lot of force
even though the technique on my side has
very little
of my force output potential
this however is not internal this is all
external
okay so let's try it with these external
elements
okay again as a beginner you are
manipulated by your mind
hence brutal hence the whole training
right
that i don't get manipulated by my ego
tripartite
by the the untrained functioning of my
mind
okay as a beginner you're going to be
manipulated by your mind
so in the same way as he is a foe and i
have a task and i have to overcome him
you're going to bring tension into you
so in the same way as i'm doing the
technique right when you hit here you
feel his resistance
that's where you flex up and you forget
the mechanical efficiency of
tension free movement so it's instead of
trying to throw him use your imagination
and
brush some fly off the wall over there
my arm's doing nothing
okay try it again okay so i've become
biomechanically efficient i have tension
free movement
uh the percentage of my force potential
output is very very small i can launch
them pretty good but
none of this is internal all of this is
external still
just because i as a beginner who is
tension burden or attention laden
i don't understand how that's possible
that doesn't make it internal okay it is
still
external but you're going to see that
a few things happen with this that are
not consistent with the art when
this is my understanding not only of the
art but of its highest ideals such as
kolkyo and eike
all that i do in my biomechanically
efficiency is make myself relatively
powerful
there is no yin yang reconciliation
whatsoever all i did with that
biomechanical efficiency
was yong yang the hell out of him that
is all you saw
okay um and that should be a clue
that maybe as few of people who can
actually achieve biomechanical
efficiency
invited that does not make it right
because i am not doing a yin yang
reconciliation
i'm simply overpowering my opponent and
that would be
no different than if i weighed 75 to 100
pounds more than
him i had my hands out to the side away
from my body
and i was tensing like a mf and i
still overpowered him it is still the
same yangyang clash
the same external movement it is not the
art
okay which is why
if he weighed 100 pounds more than me
i probably would start to have problems
with that even though i could get him to
come off my wrist or i could lift my
hand
efficiently there is a mechanical
ceiling to it because
it is nothing more than a mechanical
engine okay
kokyu and ike is something else
not that okay any athlete does that
all right tokyo ikea the internal
aspects are what i do with his
energy not my
external body but maybe my
internal body maybe okay
so um it's when he pushes
and i am letting that energy come in
and i do one or two of
the aspects of the universe i either
separate
things or i unite things okay
if i separate things i take that cue
and i put out a force value that is
greater than his
via his energy so i add energy to his
energy
or i put a force value that is equal to
his
so i let his energy pass through me and
come out
equal to his energy and that creates
that communion or that adhesion so
we're going to take the same the same
technique um
of uh tenshi nugget and we're going to
do it
in a internal way okay
um so what you're going to see is that
he's not going to be ahead of me and
then i'm just throwing him that way
so i'll i'm going to exaggerate it so
you can see
let's have you pull so he's pulling okay
he's pulling and i'm going to start
bringing him in
and his energy is going forward and i'm
going to be able to
as i bring him into my body i'm going to
adhere
at different points of my body where he
makes contact
and i'm going to turn him in space
so he's pulling go ahead and pull this
would be wrong
[Music]
are you going to uh adhere to him
and this energy is bouncing back and
forth in him that makes him
he has to step to keep his balance
he's pulling no absorb
and here keep loading him up
so here is the communion no external
internal
loading him up and when i get to the top
i project it out
absorb
[Music]
up to the top project out
so he's he's gonna go the other way
you see he's going he's going the other
way before the throw happens
[Music]
okay try it
okay so uh open your
open your hand okay and this is what i'm
doing
okay now i'm not i'm not pulling him
because that'll pull up into his front
foot
you see remember he's supposed to be
pulling backwards okay
what i'm doing is his energy is grounded
my front foot and then i'm vectoring it
over here
and it becomes more like this so see his
stance
it would be like him holding on to here
okay and i have a good
base and he pulls that energy because
that's what makes him step
it's not me doing this and leaving him
so he's pulling pull pull
pull pull pull pull that's not it
okay i'm not pulling against this pull
he's
he's going and i'm bouncing that energy
off that's what makes him take that step
okay and i just keep doing that in
between keep bouncing bouncing bouncing
and
he either goes and stumbles or he
moves his face in support so boom
boom i keep moving it around moving it
around moving it around
moving it around now he's on my
arm up here that becomes my next
adhesion point
not his grip that i try to uh fulcrum
let's move away from the jaw
so that's what i use and this is what i
use
let go but not by fulcrum or anything
i'm using this adhesion the two
adhesions
and then i'm going to load them onto my
hip and that becomes the next adhesion
so together everything goes come back
everything goes won't
so just like in cookie hole yesterday
i'm going from the grip
to this adhesion from the grip
to this adhesion this is happening here
too
so energetic warm get them on your
inside of your arm
[Music]
then here going this way the inside of
the script
onto your hip
then the cookie projection the separated
energy of the universe
okay try it if we go back to the
external version where i'm just
overpowering him uh this way you see how
he's he's standing straight up
until you overpower him
so when you guys are in your g wasn't
the uke does not have to
stay there to be overpowered the
technique does not work
okay because he doesn't have to stay
there for me to be overpowered
i'm just pushing the guy
it doesn't work so
i had him pulling on me so you can see
that he is coming forward by what
i am doing not because of what he does
okay so for example let's say he's
coming forward i still
go boom and i try to overpower this guy
so maybe it's not skilled than she was
and they don't smell that coming
and they don't counter it by either
going under it or backing out
but maybe they're still too big and i'm
just hitting people that's not aikido
and it
generally does not work okay so i
am bringing them in to another adhesion
point
so you you almost want to ignore the
grip find the
inner arm find the inner arm down here
and then find the hip so that he is
still going forward
i turn him from going forward and then
he heads
back the other way and then i enter
in that in space so just like the other
knife
i'm doing pull i trade to the arm
adhesion
he's going that way and i step into that
i do not use the edemiachi to shove him
back
he needs to already be followed so the
same thing he's going forward this time
and i'm doing the same thing
not him standing straight right away he
tilts
and goes into the back outward position
and look right away and here and here
and here
okay let's go now from the point of view
of kihomosa
the mechanical external stuff is very
important you do need to learn that
but like i said it's not the whole of
the art and
it is not the higher aspects of the art
the higher aspects of the art
are these internalized energetic
mechanics not not my external
biomechanics
and in the same way that relaxed
movement creates an efficiency
in itself outside of your posterior
chain engagement
or center line utilization you can
get a lot of force output from that
and you don't need necessarily
center line elbows or shortened levers
or things like that
in the same way when you have the
internal aspects
even though the external aspects are
important when you have the
internal aspects you can get away with
terrible
external aspects okay now
that is only relevant though from the
kihon wasn't point of view from a
tactical or real life application that's
a no no because
it's tactically unsound okay but
um you you can be goofy go ahead it
doesn't matter okay
i could be goofy and he pushes
and i do the same thing so i'll be on
a bent over posture and i'll be on
on my toes it doesn't matter
because his energy's coming in me
and as long as i have any kind of
greater mass that i can bounce it back
and forth off
it works so i don't need the full foot
i don't need mid-foot i don't need a
bent knee i don't need a lower
center i could be on my tippy toes
in the goofy posture and the energy
still
still functions
okay so keep that in mind it's not
everything
but sometimes you can do without
anything else